voy a mostrarles lo que queda de
el 24 de Julio la vida de Magda dio un
giro radical su hija saima gamal
presentadora de televisión de 42 años
Fue asesinada por su marido Un conocido
juez de la capital tras un juicio
mediatizado a principios de septiembre
el hombre y su cómplice fueron
condenados a muerte la madre de saima
sigue sin entender
siete años de matrimonio
y ese traidor la mata de la peor manera
no estamos hablando de un hombre
ignorante y sin educación no es un
hombre muy poderoso
nunca sospechamos de
unos días antes de su muerte saima gamal
publicó este video en las redes sociales
me dirijo a todas las mujeres Víctimas
de la violencia sean quienes sean por
favor corran por su vida
vayanse rápido váyanse váyanse lejos
dejen todo atrás sin pensar en nada más
que en ustedes mismas sino podrían morir
según un informe de las Naciones Unidas
de 2015 más de 5 millones de mujeres
egipcias son Víctimas de violencia
conyugal cada año sin embargo Hay pocas
estructuras que las acojan en esta ong
reciben formación trabajadoras sociales
y abogadas para ayudar a las víctimas la
asociación ha recibido a casi 600
mujeres este año una cifra que no cesa
de aumentar recibimos a mujeres que son
maltratadas físicamente y en muchos
casos el marido está desempleado y
consume drogas entonces obliga a su
mujer a trabajar y con todo su sueldo
muchas de estas mujeres no están
preparadas para el mercado laboral y acá
en lugares peligrosos donde son acosadas
y a veces abusadas sexualmente se les
explota con largas jornadas de trabajo y
salarios miserables las víctimas muy a
menudo prefieren guardar silencio
[Música]
tenía miedo del juicio de la sociedad
como mujer divorciada
de cómo me percibirían en las sociedades
orientales mucha gente piensa que una
mujer divorciada
No puede salir sola
en sal mal de uno de verdad
Esta estigmatización no es algo nuevo a
finales de los años 90 el propio
presidente mubarak se ocupó del problema
y presentó una respuesta sorprendente un
pueblo enteramente dedicado a las
mujeres viudas y divorciadas tras la
muerte de su padre hace 20 años ni
managüi y su madre fueron de las
primeras en llegar al pueblo desde
entonces nima ha vivido en condiciones
modestas
el agua no es potable conseguimos
bidones fuera Cuando llegamos no había
agua ni electricidad ni siquiera gente
hoy Gracias a Dios las cosas van bien
Mucho mejor que al principio
sin embargo debido falta de
infraestructuras la gran mayoría de las
mujeres divorciadas regresaron a sus
pueblos de origen dejando atrás decenas
de casas abandonadas algunas fueron
vendidas Saba el shows y su marido
compraron esta casa hace 10 años
las mujeres divorciadas venían se
quedaban un tiempo y luego se iban a su
casa
Así que muchos aprovechamos para comprar
esos terrenos Pero tenemos un gran
problema con las inundaciones
hay casas donde el agua sale del suelo
sube
ante una sociedad que sigue siendo
profundamente conservadora las mujeres
egipcias siguen luchando para que sus
derechos sean respetados gracias a las
redes sociales sus voces se hacen oír en
el verano de 2020 La ola del mitu se
extendió por Egipto
[Música]
Ana Parra
al año siguiente el gobierno transformó
el delito de acoso en un crimen
castigado con penas más severas Este
cambio de legislación fue acogido con
satisfacción por la ONU en su momento la
propia prensa egipcia informa ahora de
los casos de violencia contra las
mujeres nadiema broke tenía 3 años
cuando sus tíos irrumpieron en su casa y
le dispararon a su madre ocho veces su
error había sido casarse con un beduino
de una tribu diferente la joven
periodista publicó un artículo en el que
relataba por primera vez este crimen de
honor necesitaba escribir ese artículo
Necesitaba hablar porque había guardado
silencio durante demasiado tiempo quiero
disculparme con mi madre por qué he
pasado 32 años con miedo a hablar de
ella e incluso hubo momentos durante
esos años en los que la juzgué en los
que pensé que todo había sido culpa suya
se está corriendo la voz y la lucha
feminista está creciendo a finales de
marzo un grupo de parlamentarias
presentó un proyecto de ley para
combatir la violencia contra las mujeres
el texto incluye la prohibición de los
matrimonios con menores de edad y penas
de prisión para los autores de la
violencia conyugal Aunque el camino
hacia la libertad todavía parece largo
las mujeres egipcias están decididas a
recorrerlo